Shark Tank has now become one of the
most successful TV shows.
Crazy.
That you produce. Now that you've been
on this show for 15 years, you look
back at it and you look back at the
start, right?
For people that do not know, Mark, how
does Shark Tank start?
How did they come to Mark Cuban?
Okay. So there's two two questions
there, right? How did it start? It
started in Japan. Then it went to
England and then it came to United
States. It was called Dragons Den over
there. And then Mark Burnett got Ahold
of it, changed it, Americanized it.
And they asked me initially to be on
when it was going to start in 2009.
Then they decided against me.
They put this other dude on and then,
you know.
What other dude was?
Kevin Harrington There you go. Yeah.
Yes, Yes. And so anyways, that didn't
work out. So they came back to me and
they're like, Well, we want you to
audition. I'm like, fine.
I don't care. Right. This is season
two. So they sat me down and it was out
here in LA and I was hung over.
They just called me in the morning.
Can you come and do it? I was hung
over. It's been a good day.
Yeah, it was in a good market.
Yeah. The good days, the good days hung
over, and so they're just.
And I'm just being honest, right?
And they're like, okay, do you want to
do three episodes?
I'm like, they had, Oh my God, who's
the You might be a redneck, Jeff.
Jeff Foxworthy. Yeah. Jeff Foxworthy,
Right. And so he did three and I did
three. And I'm like, this show, like,
it's on Tuesday night, one night, one
week, and it's on Sunday night to
replace Desperate Housewives.
It ain't going to last, right?
So I'm going to go on there. I'm just
going to f*** them up.
Yeah, right. I'm just going to buy
everything and freak them out.
And that's what I did, man.
And it just it turned out I had so much
fun. And like you said, it's real.
And the response from people was
insane. The companies were okay, but it
was just okay. This is the American
dream. Absolutely. On network
television every week.
And you get- well, now it's two sided,
right? Because now you guys are a part
of really amplifying these companies.
There's real success stories that have
come from Shark Tank. What do you feel
is the biggest miss from Shark Tank?
You know.
People think it's ring.
I don't yeah, I don't at all because
they had to raise me by the way. Yeah.
Jamie Smart.
Very.
Smart guy got that taken away from him
but he had to raise.
Very well now.
But they had to take they had to raise
so much money. Yeah, right.
To get where they were. And to me,
that's. That's rare that that can
happen. Most entrepreneurs can't raise
three, 4 or $100 million.
To me, the one that got away personally
was Spike ball. Okay.
You know Spike Ball.
I don't now what it is. Right?
You know, you go to the beach here in
LA, it's everywhere, right?
What's the biggest game? It's one of
like the biggest. Yes. Community games,
connecting.
People on a beach. Kids, guys, you know,
girls, whatever, teenagers.
And like, now when I go come out to LA
or we go on vacation somewhere and it's
on the beach and I see Spike ball all
the time, I'm like, F***!
Because the guy looked at me and said,
Mark, I really want you to do this.
I'm like, It's cool.
It's nice. Mark, I really want you to
do this. I'm like.
There is nothing worse.